hello and welcome to the Evan Carmichael
show i am your host up in carmichael I
believe in entrepreneurs and I am on a
mission to help you believe I want you
to believe that what you're doing is
right that you're following your passion
that you're doing this to the right
reason not just trying to make a lot of
money I want you to believe that you can
do it to have the confidence to know
that you have the mindsets of vision the
ability to execute that you can make
your dreams happen and I want you to
believe that little workout to have the
conviction to follow through the first
severe that that if you keep going your
dream will come true and I know it's
hard I know it's hard I know you may you
may think you know I don't have the
money to make the time I don't have the
contacts I don't have anybody in my
family to support me up nobody around me
does gonna be successful you may think
that you know I've been trying and then
I've been trying to get this thing to go
I've been putting myself into this and
it's not working i'm not seeing momentum
marketing growth I've hit plateau when I
can't buck through you know what is it
my turn when is it my turn if that's you
then this show what's for you I want to
help you because I was there and I know
a lot of times small but powerful
changes can make the difference between
being successful and not hitting your
dream
today's show is all about social media
success in an upcoming edition of Forbes
I'm going to be featured as one of the
top 40 social media marketers online and
they asked me a bunch of questions and I
don't know how much it's going to make
it into the magazine I have some pretty
controversial views that a lot of people
don't agree with but it's led to a lot
of success on social media and so I want
to share that with you guys today
because a lot of entrepreneurs are
trying to figure out how do I make
social work for me because I'm just
wasting my time on this thing I'm not
going to end the results and you know my
time is important I have a million
things to do I want just blow time away
sitting there on the social networks how
do i fix this so that's what this show
is all about let's get start let's kick
it off the first question I got asked by
Forbes is can you give any specific
strategies tips examples of how to use
social media to generate leads and this
is one of the most common questions that
I get out how do I get leads some social
media right how do I put stuff out there
that people pay attention to and then
end up buying for me this is really
important okay the most important rule
in social media is that you need to
stand for something you should care
about what you're sharing if it wasn't
you or your company making whatever
you're putting out whatever you're
tweeting whatever you're putting on
facebook if you wasn't you puttin it up
would you actually want to share it
that's the test is probably not look at
what you're posting is coupon codes
you're broadcasting you're saying here's
the link to my latest blog post nobody
cares about that stuff it doesn't make
me feel anything your content is boring
and you know what welcome to the club
most companies content is born most
people content is born but if you pose
boring stuff you won't get results
that's why you're not getting any people
calling you and following you and buying
your stock because your stuff is born
makes me feel something with each post
you should feel proud you should feel
proud and get excited by the content
that you're creating and sharing if
you're not proud and excited with every
tweet you put up then it's not going to
work stop it start over
you can get a great ROI from social
media but you have to know how to use it
you've got to inject feeling into it a
lot of people look at social media and
they treat it like advertising right if
you think about advertising see you have
a cost-per-click can't change you know
that it's my next amount of dollars
you'll get extra more people to see it
why number people will click through
your page and the number of people will
buy right that's a typical advertising
model you know if you spend more you'll
get more it's not that directly
measurable in social you get results but
you can't say if I spent one more hour
on Twitter I'm going to get X number new
leads that's not how it work it's not
like pulling a lever so stop treating it
like advertising
I've gotten tons of great results from
social but I don't know which one is let
getting customers to me so I don't know
which YouTube video or which tweet or
which facebook post is going to lend me
a deal what I know that by creating
content that I care about and I feel
passion about I get results so here's
this was example a recent came back from
speaking at a conference in Malaysia
they flew me over they paid my speaking
fee they gave me the LD the airfare
hotel transportation to everything all
expenses paid plus my speaking fees and
when I got there like this is a great
opportunity i made tons of great
connection how do you guys find me
and their answer when we saw your
YouTube videos and had to have you come
it was through social and this happens
every day when you create great content
that you're passionate about this
happens every single day this is the
difference she's going to look at the
stuff you're creating you have to start
step ticket stuff I forget about social
for a minute take it step back and think
about what is my company stand for why
did I start this business what greater
purpose do I have here besides trying to
make money what do I want the world to
look like right this is important you're
doing this your reason you're doing this
to help people you make money by helping
people and adding value how do you want
to help people what kind of companies do
you want to build what do you stand for
when you figure that out
then that's your guiding beacon it's
your guiding light for everything that
you do not just social but everything
that you do I try to convince people to
get down to one word take one word that
makes your company come a lot what's
your one word biography so for me it's
believed and then when you have that one
work it's so easy to create social media
campaigns it's so easy to find
everything out with your business if you
look at the stuff on my Twitter account
my facebook page my youtube video is all
is about beliefs somehow but believe in
the little guys believing in the
entrepreneur you know we might share
post about how a successful entrepreneur
didn't make it we know this was was
looked down upon everybody said he'd
never make it and ended up turning
around talking about people like Marilyn
Monroe who their first studio gigs that
she got she got fired from because it
said she wasn't pretty enough to be an
actress Marilyn Monroe wasn't pretty
enough to be an actress or you look at
Oprah Winfrey who her first TV gig they
fired her and they said you're not fit
for TV Oprah Winfrey not fit for TV
right these are the kinds of things that
I share they have meaning for me they
get me excited I'm proud of what I put
up there's a lot of feeling in each one
and as a result people share it people
want to connect with me people want to
subscribe and you don't want to get on
social and use it as a sales channel ok
she'll end up happening but social
social media is about building
relationships want people to say wow
that Evan guy you share an important
stuff I want to follow him and that
people get to know you like you trust
you to become more curious they want to
know what you're doing and then they can
see all the products that you're selling
I sell a ton of product i sell i sell
almost 40 different products of my
website i sell webinars i sell
advertising and sponsorship and major
partnerships with big brands i sell
workshop and i sell speaking engagements
i sell lots of stuff i get a lot of
leads through social but i never almost
never in pitching my
products through social you use social
media as a way to gain attention as a
way to spread a movement as a way to get
people excited about what you're doing
and then as a result of that people
become curious and you visit your
website and see what you're all about
and then look at your product and
services because you have to first let
people know that you're someone that
cares that's it children people that you
care if you can do that then they'll buy
all your products or services so take a
minute and think about what is your
company's stand for right what's the one
thing that you are accomplished in this
world your mark the market you want to
leave the dent if you want to put in the
universe what is that what's the one
word and then start applying that to
your social media campaign
and look at is the stuff I'm sharing
meaningful does that make me feel
something now am i proud of this because
every single post you need to be proud
of it's not then you got to start over
and it's definitely a focus on quality
you gotta focus on quality don't worry
about posted a tweet every single day
and says do one we can make it amazing
make it the best what you've ever put on
today we're talking about social media
success I'm also rose taking your calls
and answering your questions I'm going
to be featuring Forbes magazine as one
of the top 40 social media marketers
online and I was I what are your
predictions for social media lead
generation to the next 12 months where
do you see things going you know it's
funny it's getting noisier it's getting
noisier every single day more and more
people are going to soldier more and
more companies of exciting he needs to
get on social we need to promote our
conference we need to build our own
movement going on here so it's harder
and harder the standard
the opportunity here though is that most
companies are just broadcasting and
they're already being tuned out there
already not getting any result that's
why you're not getting any shares or
likes and comments and more and more
companies are going to struggle the next
to 12 months what's my prediction that
more and more companies are going to
struggle to get an roi to get is more
more people getting online you know
you're somebody's facebook feed you go
to your Facebook ok you have a news feed
right your friends are showing up there
may be a few other companies you've
liked some of their stuff is showing up
the guys are doing a good job but you
don't have any more time to spend on
your news feed your new chickens and
expanding right he's find your X amount
of time on Facebook that's the amount of
time you spent yet more and more
companies are coming online trying to
promote their stuff so now you're in a
much bigger competition is more than
people trying to do this and again the
way for you to stand out is your sub
past the important has to be shareable
actually something that people care
about the people who come with the wrong
mindset the wrong approach the people
coming trying to just make it an
advertisement play at broadcasting play
they've already lost they're not going
to get results so don't make that you
make yourself and poured care about it
that's how you can stand out I want to
get to the calls i have amber on the
line every where are you from how can I
help oh hi how are you thank you
pleasure to speak to you this morning
I'm actually from Connecticut and I have
you know work at small flower business
as I started about I'd say about 10
months ago okay revolution it yeah I
should I like to expand it actually like
you were talking about it and you're
like into the internet but you know I'm
really unsure how to do that so I was
wondering if you could help me out you
know with some advice or you know give
me some kind of roadmap you know is to
you know how are you you know push out a
little bit do you have to have a retail
location no actually I shall my whole
ass out of your house okay and what's
different about this flower shop well I
have a lot of exciting flowers you know
that Allah shop don't carry so my
varieties you know what I would say is a
standout variety
around they can it be a little upper end
why are people buying your flowers well
because they want something different
you know like not the run-of-the-mill
that by another night for special
occasions we open parties you know
things like that and how are people
finding you right now mostly a word of
mouth and also through some local
advertising that I do okay and i thinkI
being able do people come to your house
to see the flowers or you go to them and
show them pictures how does the process
work well I thank you I work either way
sometimes I'll go out you know with a
few [ __ ] like you know what samples made
up or sometimes they'll come to me but
or you know I go out to them you know as
a service yeah I'm wonder if that if
that can be your value I you know that
that you help consult with them and show
them samples and work with them to come
up with a plan no but I want to like it
but I want to put that you know online
how do I do that well no one's your goal
of one online right if you're if you're
targeting corporate parties big event
then it's a different model than trying
to sell to the you know the husband who
just want to buy some flowers or his
wife so who's your target market who do
you want to go out there well I still
have to be good markets like what I was
doing was taking pictures of some of the
things that lets say I go out where and
you know you you know instead of going
out so much maybe putting them on a
website it's great to have an online
president to be a source for you I'm
assuming you don't have any you know
technology experience yourself but you
have people in your family or anybody
can think of who can help you with it um
I do all right you know I was thinking I
could even budget some money and fire
somebody not just on a temporary basis
nobody could get it going what i would
do is think about you want to get it
right as much as you can the first time
right you want to keep having to spend
way too high
somebody over and over and over and over
again so I got to think about what is
the unique values that you bring and who
is his website cater shoot so your
unique value is going to be that you're
different that you have a dog flower and
that you you know have this extra
service when you work with them to
create their events of fantastic event
that's great and if you're you know if
your market is going to be corporate
parties then you have a framework to
start a website around because if you
keep changing it and you have to go back
and front another thousand-dollar
another thousand dollars to update it
each time to add all these new things in
so if we get item up right you want to
figure that out and you've already got a
got it going so just add a little more
clarity to it when you're adding a new
website one of my favorite platform was
called WordPress I don't know if you've
heard of it or not but it is barely
noticeable it's called WordPress so Oh
what I would recommend you find somebody
who can help you with WordPress you can
even go check this out typing can go
into Google i'm typing wordpress
template and there's a bunch of them
that are free and a bunch of them that
are paid but there are some that around
flower shops as well so you don't have
to spend as much work with designing and
updating it and the great thing about
wordpress is once its installed you need
to have somebody help you install it but
once its installed you can do all the
editing and updating yourself it's like
using a word document you can use word
you can use wordpress oh okay okay that
sounds good also it's not too
complicated super easy so that's that
that would be much not too much for you
you start with figuring out you know
what's your unique value that you bring
to with your target market and design
content to serve them and take great
pictures and showing your samples and
bouquets everything that you do to
support those clients and then go out
and find somebody just to install
WordPress for you you can do a search
for the templates see what you like say
install this and then the updates you
can do for the most part of yourself
adding new content adding new pictures
you can do that all yourself without
having to get any help oh okay that
sounds great all right good luck amber
oh happy one year or more very much
alright and for everybody listening get
online it's important way to show what
you're doing right people like to see a
website as a way to look at and you know
it's a little bit of validity the people
some people have a version of dealing
with someone who's just out of our home
and a website can meet you look a lot
more professional I'm continue on with
my advice for entrepreneurs and their
social media campaigns and I got ass
from forbes magazine from an employer's
perspective what are the advantages of
hiring marketers a lot of clout what are
the risks so if you guys are know what
cloud is climate is KL 0 UT go to Klaus
com kou qi calm and what they do
basically is tracked everybody on social
media attracts their scores it gives
everybody a score so I'm a club 70
that's pretty high you're just getting
started in social media you'll be you
know in the low teens low 20s and and
everywhere in between the pen and how
successful you are so the question that
was asked my father should I hire
somebody for marketing based on their
clothes and first of all I love that
we're talking about hiring people to
manage a social media campaign to too
many entrepreneurs they look at how do i
outsource this who can i do to do some
quick social media stuff for me you
can't outsource this you gotta do it
yourself or have somebody on your team
do it for you but you can't other
sources to another company for social to
work the person doing it has to have the
sole right your campaigns need to have
sold they need to have feeling and that
comes from someone inside your company
now cloud is one not just to look at it
if you're hiring somebody can do
marketing and social campaigns you can
look at the club score it has flaws a
lot of people will hate on clothes but
you know what if you see somebody knows
at Club 70 going up against the club 15
you can safely assume without Club 70
person knows a lot more about what
they're doing online then the club 15
the different una club 17 x + 65 not
that big okay that may not be the
deciding factor for you but again if you
take it out bringing somebody on your
team you got to back this out and think
about
is the person going to be a good
cultural fit for me right back to number
one what are you stand for is a company
what is your company's sole because you
can't bring on somebody may be great at
what they do and this isn't just social
media you're looking to bring around a
programmer you looking at bringing on
anybody in marketing or sales person you
look at bringing anybody in your teens
they sort of get what you do because the
skills aren't enough you can always
train skills you can't train values a
Nike cantering on a marketing manager
who doesn't love athletics even if
they're closed stores off the chart even
this is the greatest marketer of all
talk if that person doesn't love
athletics then you can't go work at Nike
that's how it is you got to figure out
what is your company stands for there's
a buddy of mine named Louie he wants a
company called last minute training and
his company's all about giving training
the people you want to buy excel
training words training whatever it is
ignore the last minute training column
you can check it out you can get a great
training course his word is delighted he
likes people to feel delighted when they
come to his website when they deal with
his company when they call in to his
agents he's not just selling training
he's selling them experience and this is
the word that means something to him he
wants people to always yield Eliza and
the matter what company he brings us to
he's always going to feel that he wants
his customers to feel delighted and so
if he's bringing on somebody that worked
for him and he's going to the sponsors
right now he's hiring a sales person
powering a marketing person that person
has to believe in making the customers
feel delighted because no matter how
great a job they do want sales and
convincing people to buy and making
connections if they don't delight the
customer then there's not going to fit
it in his comfort and when he's looking
at creating social media campaign it's
got to be around delighting the customer
things that make the customer delight it
that's what he's all about if you're not
that person you're not going to finish
the company so you need to get that
specific with your own business
right 19th of letters Louise business is
about being delighted minus about police
what is your company all about I mean
you hire people who helped with that
mold and you create social media
campaigns that speaks to that vision the
next question I asked was what is best
in class companies do to empower
employees to use social media as part of
a sales and marketing process one thing
that drives me nuts and worked with
companies for trying to do their social
media campaigns is they try to control
what happens stop trying to control what
happens the companies and the brands of
wind will be the ones that let the
conversation happen you can't control
the conversation right if somebody's up
there talking about your company you
can't control that all you can control
is your reaction to it and this is a
great way to get started the way I got
started on social media was I thought it
was stupid about to where was a waste of
time that's different why would I you
know I'm a busy entrepreneur on time for
this people talk about their tax and
what's neat for lunch I'm going to waste
time on this and then I did a search to
our name and I found that people were
talking about my company and I wasn't a
part of the conversation now they're all
saying good things which is great but
you need to at least be a part of the
conversation that's how I justified it
to myself to get online to get on
Twitter just start interact with people
because people where they're talking
about me but you can't control that
conversation so what a great companies
do they hire great people who love the
mission right again what are you staying
for who eat sleep and breathe what you
do then you give them training and the
tools they need to succeed and you turn
them loose let them come up with
creative ideas
ready to be thinking about bringing
somebody on amuses just an intern you
don't have a full time employee doing
this get an intern to help you with this
who but who love your company right who
loves everything that you stand for
you want to use social media as part of
your sales and marketing process stop
blacks on the coupon codes and
promotional offers stop just sharing
your blog posts because they're born and
nobody cares about it are you actually
seeing any results from those things no
nobody gets results in that instead
focus on the customers if you're trying
to think how do I use and give me some
practical tips ok how do I use social
media as a way to connect with people to
care about them to show them that I
really you know mean business all of
them on Twitter right look at your
customers follow your best customers on
Twitter somebody comes into your store
they have a company look their company
up follow them on Twitter engage in some
congratulate them you're not selling
stuff we just trying to stay top of mind
just trying to be a friendly face
if they have a youtube video comment on
it congratulate them if they post
something on linkedin they say post a
victory they post an update say well
done care about them that's all you have
to do is chair about them we're
implementing a strategy where you care
about your customers and your prospects
stop trying to push products down their
throats and actually care about them if
you do that don't care about you right
that's your first step that's what
social media is all about imagine like
you're going to a networking event you
got to give value first you got to get
people to like you to know you to trust
you to care about you you're not going
to networking event Jane hi I'm Evan
please read my latest blog post you do
that you're not going to win it seems it
seems ridiculous and yet people are
doing this online every single day on
social media you have to go and give
value first show that you care ask
questions interact with them then
they'll buy from you right if they care
if they know you right if you're staying
talk with mind with them okay you look
at a prospect prospect is dealing with
your company and potentially by other
companies whatever you sell you sell
flowers right either last color amber
util flowers if you're following
somebody on Twitter you're engaging with
them you're talking to them you're
congratulating them you got pushing
anything you just responded to the stuff
that they're putting up
you're going to take top of mind they're
going to feel like they know you they
like you they trust you when it comes
down to making the decision of who to
give a big order to it was between you
and five other companies who they're
going to go with you know soon when you
can offer the same relative product that
product isn't the factor who are they
going to go with they're going to go
with you because they'd like you they
know you they trust you they'll buy from
you they'll refer business to you if
your competitor drop their prices by 2%
they won't lead you to go there that's
what great companies do that's how to
leverage social so hands-on tactical
stuff build a list right now think about
your top customers your top prospects
people you want to do business with and
start to follow them look them up on
facebook you can have a page let them up
on youtube team you have a channel put
them up on twitter if you have an
account and just start engaging with
them respond to their stuff congratulate
them give them ideas not not about your
stuff right we're not we're not
promoting our product we're just staying
top of mikes the people who engages me
the most people who comment on my stuff
you know what i do i can check out their
page i see what they do i'm curious you
piqued my interest I want to learn more
about you and sometimes we do business
together the guys who pitched me to say
Evan check out this deal Evan sign up
for my opportunity I've been go buy my
book Evan go by my flowers I don't do it
right you don't respond to that either
so start reaching out and it's fun he
interact with customers is fun but you
have to have the right mindset of caring
welcome back to the Evan Carmichael show
I believe in entrepreneurs just before I
went to break I promise I get the Josh
so Josh where are you from welcome
aboard how can I help hey Evan thanks
for taking me I'm from New York City I
have a baseball fantasy app that I've
just in its early stages and i'm looking
to create a beta now actually have
someone helping me so we're looking to
create a stapler metrics app and a saber
metrics fantasy app and i'm wanting to
know what would be the best way to get
some social media presence and get
people excited about this on the
internet so are you
trying to help people pick players for
their fantasy team it would be like an
alternative to fantasy baseball based
off of the sabermetrics system what is
the opportunity was going to help me
pick players or are you going to create
your own fantasy league that I could
sign up for it would be its own fantasy
league based on a different statistical
system than what fantasy statistics
systems are based off of now got it okay
cool is that a big problem for people
who do fantasy baseball they feel like
the metrics that are being used right
now or are there not good I think there
is a subculture of people who are more
into baseball and there's like subgenres
of baseball fantasy leagues that is what
would take interest in this and so now
you're thinking how do you get this
thing out but how do you get the word
spread about it exactly I would start
looking at who is talking about super
metrics and its really passionate about
about how it spread the word for you mmm
no so is a cute there's a few baseball
games software games that I'm a fan of
one is old cheesy baseball and you know
these guys started using sabermetrics in
their in their software's a way to pick
your team's everything because there is
such a such a demand so many people call
in and wrote into this a hey you guys
need to have sabermetric measures to so
when you're doing your fantasy GM in the
software you can you can use those those
metrics as well so there's there's
definitely a core group love this and
it's slowly expanding to become more and
more mainstream like every major league
team now has a figure metrics guy on
staff we're 20 years ago didn't happen
right right yeah so I mean people are
writing about is people are blogging
about that people are already tweeting
about sabermetrics if you are into
nobody else doing this with this kind of
alternative fantasy league not that i'm
aware of i know there have been old like
you had mentioned OTP and there is older
fantasy systems that were just based off
of many many years back they were based
moral sabermetrics but now it's more
just off of the basic statistics that
baseball Jenner
go by yeah and it's such a huge industry
to its kind of shocking the nobody's
done this anyway offer jam for you yeah
exactly I mean so you got to be ready
for the launch of next next year right
or you're going to do like industry with
it on your wall or a month once a month
mm-hmm can you do mommy more game for
once a month or you're looking launched
from that angle you I think it would be
more of a month to month but I'm looking
for so to get it ready for next season I
think the seasons already been broken in
two yeah there I mean there are so many
people who talk about sabermetrics then
I think if you just reach out to them
and let them know what you're doing if
you if you're the third it's something
that people want to share I'm not even a
baseball I'm a baseball fan but I don't
worry right about everything too much I
mean I'm interested I'm expensive like
so I think it's something that people
would treat you the hard core tegra
metrics guys and there's a lot of them
online we're tweeting and yeah ends up
on YouTube and Facebook it's just a
matter for each genetic and maybe now is
your chance to start you know if you
know you're going to launch next year
start reaching out to them now I must
know what you're doing and maybe even
get their input on some of the things
you're working on so that they feel like
they were involved in it too I mean
we're not launches them more likely to
want to help you promote it great great
i'll definitely have a few people that
I've already been talking knew that work
for some of the baseball card companies
and for Major League Baseball so I'll
reach out to them and also see if
there's more of the sabermetric people
that I haven't already throughout the
internet was it who's the king of
sabermetrics what's his name is Bill
James Bill James create was a pioneer of
it yeah okay and now he works for the
Red Sox right yes yeah yeah okay I mean
I'm trying to think for the main guys or
the sleeping angel singer metrics
because the guys who I follow on Twitter
or more like the Ken Rosenthal kind of
guides are I don't know how much
sabermetrics they're really in queue
then more about reporting the news but
the guides how about the guy that is a
fan graphs and
mm-hmm people who are heavy into staff
numbers right those guys are going to be
they're going to love this idea like
they even they may even be in their own
fantasy pools and saying come on you get
it you get points for a win just as this
is a super metric we should be looking
at with or something else right yeah
that like these statistics play way more
into how the game how a game plays out
and you can figure out way more from
looking at these statistics as opposed
to just simple statistics like a like
RBI as opposed to whip or any more of
the advanced sabermetrics deaths ok so
we've seen out to the guys reach out to
the top player in that field I think is
a definite left wing for you and start
now with our builds relationships the
other thing I would look at it start
creating content around why the current
system doesn't work and you can maybe
expose some flaws you can look at you
know who who the top people are on the
baseball fantasy leagues right now
putting the traditional metrics and say
these guys shouldn't be number one two
and three right like you know whoever it
is I Miguel Cabrera shouldn't be number
one it should be micro because of these
reasons and that kind of content yeah
it's something people will share may be
eaten on the bleacher report or any of
them you know bloggers mean blog sites
or baseball I know we're generating some
bud and link back to your website is you
know there's a maybe there's like a call
to action sign up for your newsletter
that kind of stuff to start building
some bus you're not just waiting until
you launch you have a whole kind of
built up anticipation yeah so just keep
it stream going yeah I get a little
hesitant so I'm thinking that what
you're saying like I should definitely
just break right into it and just are
building relationships and see what I
can do yeah start going good luck and
let me know to Josh when it said yeah
will do Evan thank you so much so thanks
for calling in another great show i love
talk to you guys i want to thank my
producers daniella and fernanda's you
guys are awesome as usual i am back in
two weeks continue to believe in your
business and
we'll see you soon